um let's see we're hearing from so many
different people here
uh why don't we go to uh skyler from new
york skyler from new york you're on the
air
hey david can you hear me yes i can
awesome so uh i was wondering obviously
for the better part of a year we've been
talking about let's just get the ball
back let's just have
a win and then we can push him left um
how do
we make the next four years productive
and that we're not just comparing
everything biden does
to what trump did but to actually push
him left and pressure him and educate
people to vote
in in more of their best interests well
the first step is we have to compare
biden to his campaign promises
and you're absolutely right that if we
simply say this is how it compares to
trump
everything will essentially be better
maybe we'll stumble across something
where we say wow
biden somehow is even worse than trump
on this one
issue i i think those issues will be few
and far between if any
but i think the first step is we
as progressive media have to remind the
audience
not just about what trump would have
done but what did biden promise that's
the start and if
if we forget that then we don't stand a
chance and then beyond that
obviously with the midterms uh and
hopefully
growing influence for the progressive
caucus in the house of representatives
there will be uh continued pressure on
on joe biden but
the most important thing is let's keep
let's hold joe biden accountable to his
own promises
yeah because like i've already seen when
it comes to like people he's named in
his cabinet
or the way that he's gone about just
like trying to work with republicans
that he's already getting a lot
of pushback from the left and then i'm
also saying like guys let him actually
be
president for a week before we start
criticizing him yeah and
on working with republicans i think all
there
is so far to criticize is what is there
to criticize biden has said he wants
unity and he looks forward to making
progress with his friends across the
aisle like he likes to say
there's nothing wrong with him saying
that it's naive if he thinks he's going
to do it because they're not going to
they will be obstructionist clowns but
i think it's silly to criticize biden
for saying it i think what
biden would be wrong to do is to think
that he'll be able to negotiate with
these people when they when he won't but
so far i don't i don't think there's any
criticism that would be levied
just for biden saying he's going to try
it i think it's great to say let's try
to work together and get things done
as long as he doesn't end up
compromising on what he campaigned on
yeah i just don't know the most
productive way to raise the bar
because if you look at the obama
administration it's easy to compare it
to george w bush and say obama
did a tremendous job but obviously if
that was the case it wouldn't have led
to the election of trump
well that's why i think it's remember on
paper
biden's campaign platform is well to the
left of obama's
i i would argue that joe biden's
platform
and his campaign promises are the most
progressive of any president that has
become
president now we have to hold him to
them if we do
if biden does the stuff he promised
then we're going to be moving the
overton window left
if biden comes back from his promises
and just
operates as a centrist then we're going
to be extraordinarily disappointed
absolutely yeah so i guess you know all
we could do at this point
is wait and see and make our voices
heard in the most productive way
possible
absolutely and make your voices heard
through your your local representatives
by i mean your members of the house and
senate that represent where you live
yeah well thankfully my representative
is centric kathleen wright so i have a
lot of work to do
okay yeah that's an uphill battle
all right thank you all right my friend
thank you so much let's take a quick
break
if you're holding don't hang up because
we're going right back to the discord
tubes for more phone calls in a moment
one of our sponsors is four sigmatic the
company
best known for their delicious mushroom
coffee
four sigmatics mushroom coffee is
organic
fair trade single origin arabica coffee
with both lions maine and chaga
mushrooms chaga mushrooms have actually
been shown to have potential in
supporting the immune system
in peer-reviewed studies i've been
drinking four
sigmatic coffee a lot lately it actually
doesn't taste anything like mushrooms it
just tastes like
any delicious coffee but it's really
easy on my stomach doesn't give me any
jittery feeling or a midday crash
and they have over 20 000 five star
reviews and best of all if you don't
love it
you'll get 100 percent of your money
back because
they stand behind their product you've
got nothing to lose by giving it a try
four sigmatic is giving my audience up
to forty percent
off and free shipping when you go to
four sigmatic dot com slash pacman
the link is right underneath this video